- Hi there, it's me, Ross Matthews.
Hi, it's Ross Matthews.
It's Rapid Fire Ross.
I'm here with Helen Dealtry.
Hilton Carter.
Zoe Francois.
Lindsey Kurowski.
Jenni Yolo.
I'm gonna ask you
questions that, you know,
really don't even deserve to be asked,
but we're gonna have fun.
(upbeat music)
What is your worst baking fail?
- Delivering a wedding cake.
The cake collapsed on the way
- No!
- To a wedding and I still
have a physical response
whenever I think of it.
- What is the best dessert
you've ever tasted?
- So depending on my mood, it's probably
devil's food cake.
- Mm.
- Covered in maybe a coffee buttercream
or, and ice cream.
Cake and ice cream.
Oh my God, it's so simple.
- I feel like even this
conversation is off my diet.
What is one tip to help people out there
who just wanna try it?
- Okay, okay, so it's not
an entirely sexy answer,
but getting a kitchen scale.
It changes the entire game
because then everything
is always consistent.
It's actually less clean up.
- Mm hmm.
- And everything just comes out better.
- And one final question, be honest,
do you watch yourself on "Zoe Bakes"?
- Okay, I don't watch myself,
but my kids and my dogs
are often on the show
and I do love to see them on the show.
- Okay.
- So yes, I watch it.
- Just be honest.
You watch yourself.
Who isn't watching you?
Thank you, Zoe.
Wow, you are tall. Okay.
That's better.
I'm gonna ask you rapid fire
questions about house plants.
- Bring it.
- How do you keep one alive?
'Cause I can't do it.
- Well, I would say love, patience,
probably a bit of tenderness.
You did say how do you keep
a relationship alive, right?
- Nope, just plants. But thank you.
- Plants!
- That's all good takeaway
for relationships or plants.
Should I be afraid of Venus fly traps?
Because I saw "Little Shop of
Horrors" and it scarred me.
- Love "Little Shop of Horrors."
One of my favorite films.
Unless you're a fly,
I don't think you need to be afraid.
They help remove some of those gnats.
A lot of people have gnats
when they have house plants.
They can remove those from
the environment in your home.
- What is is your all time
favorite Texas barbecue?
- Pulled pork.
- Mm hmm.
- Mashed potatoes.
- Yes.
- Macaroni and cheese.
- Okay, okay,
it's adding up now, that's a lot.
- I'm a big guy.
- Understood
- Jalapeno cornbread.
- What?
(indistinct)
All right. That's a cut, lunch. (laughs)
Would you rather stay
in a hotel or a motel
and what's the difference?
- Great question. Motel all the way.
- Why?
- First of all, I drive everywhere.
I drove here. It took
me 20 hours to get here.
I'm a driver. I like to
park the car in front.
- You know, in Los Angeles,
it takes you 20 hours to
get anywhere, you know?
- Yeah, I live there and yes it does,
you're correct.
- As you are traveling around,
as you're looking at
different hotels and motels,
what's a trend that needs to go?
- Oh, this is a great question.
I hate a popcorn ceiling.
I think everyone does.
- Mm hmm.
- Oh the carpet.
Listen, the carpet that
has the design in it,
so you can't see that your
kids puked everywhere.
- Yeah.
- Ew.
- Yeah. That's terrible.
Do carpet, tile, or hardwood.
- Do you watch yourself?
- I'd like to be cool and say no,
but yes I absolutely.
- Yes you absolutely do.
Who wouldn't?
What's the number one tip
for people who are looking at
that wall or that project
and thinking, "Ugh."
- Paint! Gotta use paint.
- Really?
- Paint's cheap. It's easy.
You can fix it relatively, like,
it's not a ton of commitment,
and you can grab a paintbrush,
you can just start
splotching on some stuff
and make some wallpaper looking.
I do that in the workshop.
- Really?
- Yeah!
- What's the color right now
that you would recommend?
Like the hot color of the moment?
- I mean, dark colors.
Like a dark maroon, a dark
plum, something like that.
- What's different about Texas design?
I mean we're here in Waco.
Do you bring in sort of Texas
into your DIY and your home decor?
- I've done a little shiplap in my houses,
but I like doing it vertical,
to do a little bit different
than the Texas style, but.
- Can you spell Texas backwards?
- Oh, this is my nightmare
from middle school spelling bee.
S, A, S, E.
S-A-X.
(laughing)
E-T.
(bell dinging)
- You got it, you got it.
You got it! Thanks so much.
Everyone watch "Handcrafted
Home Projects,"
Jenni Yolo, on Magnolia.
(upbeat music)
Let me ask you a question about flowers.
Carnations, tacky or underrated?
- Love them. Love them.
- See? See?
- They last forever.
- Mm hmm.
- Come in all sorts of colors.
They get a bad rep, but
they're one of my faves.
- So many times I get flowers
and then I feel like a day
later they're already wilted.
So what can we do to keep
our flowers to last longer?
- Well, you know what,
you gotta think about it.
Like, would you wanna be
sat in stagnant water?
Change that water every day.
- Mm hmm.
- Give them a little
snip, maybe change them.
If they're in direct light,
take them out of direct light.
- All right, and what do
you do to keep it fresh
on "Art In Bloom"?
- That's a good question.
I try and challenge myself.
So we've changed it up.
We're trying to do something
different for each episode.
Give people new skill sets to take away.
Yeah, not to put too much
pressure on yourself.
- See, I think people
bring so much pressure
when they're trying to
make things beautiful,
but it can be easy, it can
be fun, and it can be doable.
And you're showing us how to do it.
Thank you so much.
- Oh my gosh.
My absolute pleasure.
(upbeat music)